hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the evil then executioner
DLC now this is the final DLC in the
first evil within game and I say the
first one because there might be a
sequel in the works but we don't know
but this one is gonna be very very
different from the other ones because
we're not playing John Constantine nor
are we playing Nicole Kidman we're
actually playing safe face guy the guy
the big guy who's baddie and the other
one that had a safe on his face you know
you know who I'm talking about right ok
so I'm actually pretty excited about
this because whoa supposedly you're
stationed in the Victor ah no Victoriano
Victor ah no estate and if you remember
ruvik is actually from that estate and
his parents got all dead and stuff and
then he got all mopey about a sister
being burned alive by the entire village
which is very bad very bad not say
anything continuation of stem
operational testing examine process of
escaping system exploded by withers
subject facilitate father subjects
rescue of daughter subject who is that
huh Oh Oh your daughter is trapped
within stem imprisoned by ER connection
wait does that mean that the
wait two freer you must also connect to
stem and eliminate all other subjects
from within whoa
oh ass also as someone pointed out in
the end of the consequence DLC your
physical form within stem will not be
your own but you should find that to
your advantage so that means that I'm
some guy with motivation and that's why
I'm see that makes sense because I was
under the assumption that every single
character in the Evo then was someone
else in the system even the monsters
stems influence will eventually erase
your daughter's memories and she will
become another creature of stem that's
not good I should probably stop that but
someone mentioned that the woman who was
working with Kidman was actually
Castellanos wife like I didn't make that
connection right away we will support
you but you must act before that is
allowed to happen okay cool
that lady I'm pretty sure that lady
right there is actually Castellanos wife
which doesn't make a lot of sense you
know III don't know why she would leave
Castellanos and then join this weird
shadow organization but that doesn't
matter because now I am the big baddie
oh that's so crazy
apparently I'm like undying because when
Castellanos is trying to kill this guy
it didn't work out too well for him oh
man it's like a totally different
perspective too I'm like a lumbering of
Hemanth I mean one I'm in first-person
mode mobius directive established
synchronization final test subject has
been successfully inserted in the two
men with the safe headed creature has
been verified you should be able to use
our carrier wave to scan for residual
traces of strong emotions new directive
files will be transmitted for
replacement into the environment okay
thanks papa
Wow head for the victory ah no
Victoriano manor-house okay cool this is
so weird
I mean like when I was playing with
Kidman I think that the perspective
change
whoa I did that okay oh yeah oh I'm
gonna crouch now I don't recall the big
guy crouching at all
is this his sprint is it was that really
a sprint this a little hobble that I'm
doing here
okay so I'm gonna be able to find some
sort of mystery
hey crow you're gonna get plastered hey
you're lucky you're lucky crow you're
lucky you know nothing all right so this
must be the Victoriano boom thank you
very much
excuse me I've got a hammer delivery I
need you to sign for it with your face
anybody anybody need their face freshly
murdered no yeah you better get out of
here all righty then I guess I'll
skedaddle on my walkie never mind I'll
jump into a cutscene that's so weird
oh hello oh you oh that's so adorable Oh
throw an enemy whoa damage an enemy
until they're staggered then grab them
with B oh hey how's it going Oh give me
your face come here you aw damn it oh
there we go now I can grab oh he went
that way
I'm entering him to go another way x2
finish him off
you got it wait Oh huh oh [ __ ] they're
all well well I'm getting money I'm
getting months I'm not gonna put it in
my safe face my face safe that's hard to
say face safe face safe face safe face
safe just sounds like I'm saying feces
all right
who's in here go on some of me search
for your daughter that's so weird
the so bizarre hello dad the doctor said
you were coming to come to help me are
you ever going to get here there are
monsters all over the place I'm going
crazy
sorry daughter I'm getting a little dumb
from being this big lumbering behemoth I
can't read good yeah culture my angers
me all right so where am I going
I gotta find my daughter
see my daughter how about over here I
see my god box appears I can't pick
those up
hello what are you doing here cliff aha
is she making you angry oh okay
never mind then sorry I saw some guy
killing the monsters I think I should go
meet him and see what happens
he might know dad but just in case he's
some kind of creep I'm gonna leave my
letters and stuff here okay well that
was the third diary what happened to the
second one
find a möbius file daddy well I guess I
better wander around and find a boobies
I'll never than maybe I just want to
find my daughter anybody here seen a
little oh not Kidman I don't want any
part of her
she's a Meany poopoo head okay oh there
we go
Mobius note well that's handy that
Mobius truck to vote to eliminate test
subject murderer well that sounds good
this experiment will explore a method of
extraction from within the stem
environment your objective is to rescue
your daughter who's already inside stand
by eliminating all other connected test
subjects subject CB to one to a
convicted murderer has been completely
dominated by stem his influence grows
and he is disrupting your daughter's
memory patterns kill cb2 1 2 and ax
assess the girl's condition stem erodes
the subjects memories incrementally
gradually altering their personality and
their physical appearance until that's
finally the subjects is completely
dominated by stem based upon the data
from the rubic incident it can be
inferred that the ruvik entity was able
to leave stem the stem system by
entering the physical body of the test
subject Leslie oh this this is after oh
ok this first trial will explore stems
mental degradation effects on more
standard methods of egress transmissions
from the outside as well as tracking
within stem are subject to error and
time delays
use your own judgment and handling any
encounters connection status 7 subjects
adolescent fee bill detective twin
sibling paroled murder psychiatric ex
patient ex-soldier and father of
adolescent female so everyone else in
there detective could that be Jojo -
Jojo still be trapped in the system I
really hope it's Jojo and I don't have
to murder him I would hate to murder his
face
I like Jojo but I don't like Jojo Jojo
is nothing to me was this here are all
these other people alive are they dead
oh okay Wow I'm a big dude all right I
guess I'm no no going to see the nurse
for me just a quick saving a whoa oh
good I can open my face Oh grody so
grody barbed wire trap whoa
aw it's so cool okay get better boots
walk faster +22 walking Oh plus one -
blood pumping okay Wow there are a lot
of upgrades here dynamite damn ha
hold off is Oh
I'll hold off on that until I uh know
exactly what I'm doing here which I
probably won't I have no idea how long
this DLC is gonna be but I can assume
it's probably gonna become competent
become Capcom or a bowl to the other
ones so couple hours which should be fun
hello huh is anybody here oh I'm gonna
have fun with that one
hello who is you
aha there we go that guy said he was a
killer and his job was to kill monsters
he said that he was collecting these
weird tokens and made me help look for
them but when I tried to put one in my
pocket he started screaming got the
scary look in his eyes he might kill me
if I try to run away he might kill me if
I don't
well that's not a good situation to be
in oh nothing I thought whoever is gone
through hell ah teenagers are so
rebellious I'm sure she won't be scared
of me when I approach her what happens
if I do a little bit of this hi I'm sue
smart for you that was weird okay how
about a little bit of please please
miles you wanna please help me with this
stupid axe
listen I'm going to murder you as soon
as I find out oh there's an open door
right here are you that I'm just
pretending to be not as smart Oh lovely
last leg combo moves I can't pick you up
yet okay Wow
okay holy crap that guy is definitely
gone I didn't even get it to okay
money into my face my face safe yes
somehow I'm still greedy in here CB 2 1
2 that looks like my objective who wants
to get face murdered granny bunny in
here one fidget murderer okay I can't
pick that up either alright whoa
that is weird that's a lot of creepy
drawings and a big guy in the middle
reminds me of the Big Daddies from
Bioshock transcripts EB what do you want
- nobody said it was gonna be like this
these [ __ ] barely put up a
fight yet old broad you put me in here
might have telling me you'd be out of
time
Rudy [ __ ] put a kid in here God these
breakthroughs blew Tommy crackhead your
dad foo who you [ __ ] yet wifey I hear
you I couldn't Kris that little [ __ ]
tryin to pocket my loot what the frak I
can hear someone whispering at me you
trying to get inside my head
did you know me huh I know it's best I'm
a crazed murderer don't be giving me
your ears read that sweet little girl
girl gotta be around here somewhere
now I see what you were after
tricking me into coming here you think
I'm your lab rat do you got me I will
kill every last one of you okay
eliminate the sadist Oh what am I
looking at
I was art whoa okay well no no I'm not
ready I was gonna there was something on
the left over there I was gonna do there
was something on the Left I was gonna
explode way oh the oh the saw the
chainsaw guy I'm gonna fight the
chainsaw guy that's weird okay well good
thing I'm tactically I'd - oh don't even
try it
loser hah boink okay wait give me you
I'm gonna throw you into you now this is
the type of gameplay I can get behind
oh how about a little bit of that hey
you still alive over there can I pick up
a dead body absolutely not funk nice try
how about a little bit of a column a how
about a little bit of column a damn that
blood looks a little weird but then
again I guess a place full of zombies
probably is pretty weird the type of oh
it is hello buddy
hey buddy you ready be on an even
playing field here I bet you're not cuz
here comes the pain oh wow that that
hurt a lot oh can I block is there a way
to block like there's got to be a way to
block right no okay I'm gonna do one of
these with that there yeah why don't you
uh haha oh it didn't uh [ __ ] well uh how
do I run again that's right
switch back come on where to go oh it's
open it yeah I got you now oh [ __ ] god
damn it I forget the Run button
oh [ __ ] you're done oh [ __ ] you're done
oh wow
dammit this guy's tough
Danny's blocking all my nests whoa oh
that got him yeah I won was fun
this is oddly fun I mean it's obviously
the opposite of what it was before where
I was I was running for my life now it's
just like a combat game but hopefully
it's gonna explore a lot more of the
story and the good thing is like it
makes it acts like that very much thank
you
well well I can't be normal I mean I'm
probably normal for in here but I mean
brah I can't be normal for everything
else that's happening in here so is that
a blood showers they're gonna rejuvenate
my health probably let's see eliminate
the twin the radio daughter's memory
loss has been greatly reduced with the
deaths of CB 2 1 2 it can be surmise
that his influence on others has been
negated data indicates that your
daughter is on the move possibly with
subject CB 207 eliminate him data will
be recorded and progress progress and
stability of stem domination analyzed
dominated subjects are used to stem to
admit to emit at wavelengths which
deteriorate the memory and willpower of
others in the area this ancillary
function served to accelerate stems
domination function testing and analysis
needed to determine effect of removing a
relay point upon the stable extraction
of a subject in the target memory state
so all that fancy stuff means that the
more people going crazy in stem means
that more people go crazy faster in stem
so by removing more of the super
influenced ones I can get to my daughter
quicker and then I'll be boom Wow mama
you ain't look so good can I get a knife
can I get an ice bath please please
please
no okay hep RIS I can't open the door
politely can I I need to save a little
bit here all right would be so cool if
like the
big guy had a kitty cat to sit on his
lap every time he wanted to save but
alas that's how not it shall be hello
cute me honey I'm home
alright so that was the bar bar trap was
pretty useful but I probably could've
beaten him without but I would have lost
a lot of health in doing so let's see
defense thing where's my chainsaw oh I
can buy it I so want that that's so cool
oh it's got limited amount of fuel ok so
that's like a limited use item BAM thank
you very much
oh hey Oh clearing the execution chamber
will allow you to collect memory tokens
cool is that the thing I just used for
currency but what is this oh alright
then where's this gonna take me
all righty oh not where I expected to be
pick this up thank you who's fighting
huh come on some I got a chair huh
shove hold chair oh there you are a
little bit of Colome a little bit of
sharp Oh tits you're not gonna blow up
our wall oh that guy went off flying
that was cool the game's cool this foil
oh no you do not
so that's is what happens that's is what
happens okay so I need to make sure that
I don't use up all of my oh hey you're
gonna you're gonna applaud a wampie
stuffer on me Oh wampie stuffer didn't
even get a chance okay congratulations
you're about to be executed oh oh oh hey
bang bang bang oh right on your nards
and a little bit of column cool am I'm a
badass this makes me feel so much better
for all my failure that I did in the
other ones oh cool I can heal from that
cool cool cool
alright is there anything else that I
need to know oh hi hello how you doing
and I don't have stamina anymore can I
like charge up no okay
oh jesus what he's done okay he's done
hey dude whoops oh no no no that was the
wrong button
wrong button meant to sidestep I need to
like I'm still getting used to
everything here mang but it's oddly
satisfying I do hope that it does
uncover more of the story though because
otherwise it's gonna be feet him up even
though it is a cool one mang and a
little bit of Oh where'd you go you
gonna you're gonna turn into a thing
aren't you
hang on I'll be right with you sir
okay cool that's really fun at all oh no
you're dead oh no okay boss time boss
time this might just be a bonus room and
I don't actually need to clear it so
bonus boss
god damn it give me a boss oh he did
nevermind okay oh yes oh so cool wait
was my bag of nails that I had on my
belt maybe that's where I keep all my
coins instead of in my face might be a
little more logical okay you're done
oh it's so bad that's oh this so cool
part of me wishes I was in like third
person because that'd be like just
ridiculously cool am I supposed to like
beat these things into a pulp no no okay
well that guy what is that
okay he's gone anymore no that's it oh I
did it oh cool oh I thought it was gonna
be a boss at the end of that damnit
Pradas cuz it was an optional room but
that does mean that I get extra money
which will probably help me not that
I've been like in trouble at any point
here but I'll just go kill the other guy
call it a day
oh hey dude how's it going friend hey
you look good oh you don't look as good
anymore I mean you look good but not
that good
nevermind let's just go if you look bad
you want some you want some of this you
want some of this oh you want some of
this oh it's so yeah it's so weird
because I'm just speaking from a
story-wise I'm playing from a
perspective that I never expected I
would play out of this game and say hey
likes
oh-oh-oooh-oh-oh new oh my goodness and
it kind of brings a little bit of added
charm to it even though this the
motivation is kind of weak you are a
father your daughter in trouble
go get daughter oh yes oh I will [ __ ]
go get daughter yeah hey buddy is
getting way they get it smack uh-huh
what's your name this guy
I don't think [ __ ] is very good name
uh-oh I can teleport in here oh that's
right that's right oh oh oh that's uh
that's an interesting way to teleport
there friend ah good thing that's there
yeah I forgot that these guys are pretty
much in vulnerable well coin got it oh
you don't look so good
is everything going is everyone going to
turn into a monster there was a tall guy
I walked around with for a while because
he was lost he said he couldn't remember
where he came from he was always talking
to his brother even though you couldn't
see him he started to freak me out so I
got out of there then he started chasing
me and when I looked back he was turning
into one of those things is that going
to happen to me too this place is so
weird everything from before I came here
seems like a long time ago okay
yeah that guy that guy's not looking so
good hey your face is a little bit dead
you might want to get that looked at
okay anyone else here I remember these
locations in the Victoriano manner oh
here we go
boink who wants some cuz I got a whole
lot of some how many might want some
anybody there's a it I killed chopped
eight many things Chum Chum yum yum
let's eat up brain together chum chum
yum yum let's see the heart together
divided one child in the two children
they become stupid that's a probably a
negative outlook on children or twins
shout out to all my twin fans out there
there's got to be quite a few III never
even thought about that before lost
children my brother it is so good to see
you again losing you was unbearable
I came here to get away to find solace
somehow I knew you'd be here yes I know
we agreed to help but now I feel
conflicted no I am changing just look at
my body don't you see it why aren't you
changing you know I feel like it's not
just my body our mind is changing who do
you think the girl is surely she
couldn't be working for them that's
inconceivable you keep using that word
the girl ran away I think we I scared
her that thing at the core of me that is
not me continues to grow you feel it too
the hooded man watches me is he deaf we
can play like when we were kids
interesting conversation I'm gonna
eliminate Zen
actually you know I'm really curious
about that if you're a if you're a twin
oh those were them oh that's so cool
we're like going into the backstory of
all the actual characters in the game
hey you ready get destroyed I want to do
this a little bit oh wow
that's soaked oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh hey you can't do
that to me I'm the one who the plot II
slams people into the dirt okay I'm just
gonna whoa hey no new new new new new
new new new I'm gonna get you okay so I
got a there are guns mounted around
everywhere that I got to get to they're
gonna be used like this one right here
and then I got to be better about the
massagist point damn it that was it
really well maybe that's like the only
thing that can actually kill the dude
and I gotta use I gotta save that for
him only okay that makes a lot more
sense let me just do that quick I don't
think they would restock over time would
they
you just shut your gosh-darn mouth no I
don't have time to play with you or you
oh damn it okay hang on wait wait how do
i fire it again oh that's got a reload
okay there we go got in whoa he's going
down okay yes yes yes yes
hot damn oh [ __ ] oh snap
Oh sneeze nice new buddy okay getting
close to this guy about idea okay I
figured as much
oh wait wait wait whoa ow hey whoa hey
whoa come on I'm not gonna die just yet
I'm a little bit better at this than
that okay you doesn't look happy
neither does that guy whoa whoa he's
running he's running go go go go Oh God
not that button get out of my way
god damn it go go go Oh not good not
good not good not good not good not good
whoa okay this one's fully loaded though
okay so that's good hold on this one you
oh damn it I didn't mean to do that I
didn't need to do that come on come on
my fast recipe there we go
hey you hey buddy a little more
there we go did I get him did that do it
hey I did it but he has another brother
doesn't he
oh no that's it okay game over for him
Wow he put up a good fight no he didn't
he was a little [ __ ] okay cool huh
you can now purchase the highest maximum
ammo rank in the shop cool I didn't even
get to the point where I bought anything
in the shop I didn't even use my
chainsaw uh-huh little grody oh wow it's
so like it's so like uh it's so like uh
uh amnesia the Dark Descent whenever you
got a little bit insane and you looked
at the painting uh that don't look good
that don't look good at all either way
that's all the time AB for this episode
thank you all so much for watching I
really like this I'm having a lot of fun
with it and I'm not being absolutely
terrible so hopefully that reflects more
as I go through the game but let me know
what you figure this in below shoutout
to my twins friends again surprisingly
and then thank you all so much for
watching check out the other evil within
stuff it's all in one big playlist lots
and lots of cool stuff to go through so
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video my name
is markiplier welcome to the evil
another trip away over and watch gamers
punch the ball in anyway it doesn't
matter why this punch ball